hi and welcome to episode number 24 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I am Franciscan boy and I'm here with my
colleague mark modèle hey Mark hey
France sku doing today pretty good
pretty jet-lagged but very happy to be
back to the United States yeah we're
actually in separate places right now it
doesn't happen very often yeah yeah we
will treat about the pictures of our
Studios today their faith for carriers I
can say yep I think you're down a
mountain view I'm all the way in
Kentucky it's a lots of fun yep and
actually we're since we're traveling
both of us we were not able to interview
the same person at the same time so what
is the main content today yes so I
interviewed Terrence Shepherd with one
of our co-workers and previous
interviewer interviewees Brian Dorsey
Terrence talk to us about Google cloud
platform support was a really
interesting interview cool I am actually
so I I still haven't heard the interview
itself I Wilson but I'm sure there's
gonna be like I did you ask questions
but what is the funniest thing that has
ever happened I didn't click it the
funniest thing but I definitely got some
really interesting stories about
problems that people have had I don't
Google cloud platform like common things
or weird things and some solutions as
well cool yeah looking forward to that
and after that interview we also have
the question of the week what is the
question of the week about today so it's
not something necessarily quite as
Google cloud platform related but
definitely cloud-related and a question
we get quite often which is how to go
about coordinating or connecting say
like an app engine app or something else
on google cloud platform to other cloud
services we have a google such as like
drive or calendar yeah that is actually
a question that i've had many times so
I'm sure that many of our listeners will
consider that / useful I think so as
well about that before that we're going
to go through the cool things of the
week today with an S cuz there's
actually two of them yeah yeah so the
first one is something I for some reason
is very near and dear to my heart I have
a particular love for deployment manager
which is surprising because is you
that these things you can make them with
a big big mech file I really like to fly
our manager so if you're not familiar
deployment manager it's a way to
declaratively basically specify the
infrastructure you're on google cloud
platform i was super happy to see that
recently they have support now for
pub/sub so if you want to create topics
or subscriptions within deployment
manager you can do that through that now
you couldn't before which is really
really cool I pub/sub is a tool that I
love it's a messaging publish-subscribe
service that we run it's super super
powerful and lets you build some really
nice distributed systems yeah that is
there's actually a cool because it was
the last step so we could get rid of our
deploy script for glutton yeah now
everything can actually be done with
just one deployment manager file which
is very nice yeah I was thinking that
would be really great for cloudspinner
yeah we still need to write it but you
know exactly now what's the what's the
second cool thing of the week that we
found the second cool thing of the week
is actually the certifications and it's
about ISO certifications so recently we
got two more two more two new
certifications for the Google cloud
platform and I'm sure you have the
numbers I know that one is for privacy
and the other one is for security they
never remember the name yeah we did ISO
27001 74 cloud security and high ISO
27001 84 privacy those are the two new
ones and we also renewed our ISO 27001
certificate for the fourth year in the
road cool and this is actually covers
basically all the things in Google cloud
platform so dataflow BigTable container
engine data pro container registry
compute engine app engine etc etc
basically all the things that you can
imagine they're covered by this iso
certificate so if it's something that
it's very often it's a requirement
depending on the insula street you're
part of its always good to know that we
got you covered yeah and I think just
the general take away like we really
care about security we really care about
privacy this is just another thing that
we do in that area yeah absolutely and
we'll put it the link on the show notes
but there's a cloud the google com /
security that something
you want to learn more about absolutely
so why don't we get stuck into the
interview with Terrance with Brian
joining me as co-host does that sound
good there are sounds good let's talk to
both of them sounds great we are joined
today by Terrence Shepherd who is agreed
to talk to us about Google cloud
platform support how are you doing today
Terrence I'm doing pretty good that's
pretty great are you I'm pretty good
having a good day so far we have a bit
of a guest host today unfortunately
Francisco's traveling and I had a minor
medical emergencies we had to reschedule
a few things but Brian Dorsey is here
with us again as a guest host how you
doing today Brian hello though good day
I hope you're all healthy yes yes much
better much better go clean built ahead
today okay good excellent so um Terrence
why don't you tell us a little bit about
yourself what you do the things you do
at Google etc etc so uh my job title is
called technical solutions engineer it
is under the cloud platform support
umbrella and what I basically do is uh
customers come to the support team when
they're very anxious or they have a
problem and I'm there to help guide them
to a solution that makes them less
anxious or resolve the issue so Terrence
wheat we talked a little bit about
support you said support a couple of
times when you were explaining what it
is you do but like what is support what
does that actually mean to Google cloud
platform what's an example of a kind of
problem we help with with support um
good question uh so it really ranges on
the issue right so we'll help you
anything from any of your billing issues
like you want to change the credit card
you're paying with or you know you're
finally at a point in which your credit
card limit is less than the bill you
have on cloud platform so we'll help you
get to the next level of you know paying
via wire transfer or we call it offline
billing right where it's not like a
credit card that's charged each week
we'll help you with ah bugs you think
might be in the system will help you get
all the information needed and required
to report it to engineering will work
with engineering to make sure they're
actually
working on the bugs so customers who are
running into issues don't get that
anymore um we work on things prior to
even customers reporting problems right
so like will we look at products before
customers they even get in customer
hands we'll look at the error messages
they're going to be generated and be
like hey is that an error message that a
customer can actually use and like
figure out their own problem right you
know we very much want people to come
and ask us questions but at the same
time we want people to be able to use
the product without having to come to us
only coming to us when they're in a very
very odd situation gotcha so you're both
helping people directly and like
systematically improving things so that
you know that help isn't even needed in
the future cetera yeah basically well
sometimes we we want to keep our jobs
but at the same time yeah we don't want
to keep our cups like right so you're
actually kind of try to make things
better so that you can move on to kind
of deeper and deeper things right yeah
yeah yeah we want to we want to we don't
want to be your typical support team we
want to be the people that you partner
with and help grow your company on our
platform right when you have the
questions the tough the nitty-gritty
stuff we want to be the team you come to
or you ask advice to we don't want to be
we don't want to be the team you go to
when it's like oh I got an error right
we will we're happy to do that type of
stuff right but we don't want you to
have to come to us for that type of
question excellent so that takes it even
further than we usually think about
support yeah we're really not your like
average support team we very much try to
be the best at what we can do right um
like we we spend a lot of time uh well I
think a lot of people spend a lot of
time interacting with support teams and
you know like you know your cell phone
providers you know you have to go to
them because something's not working
right not to knock any cell phone
providers but sometimes when you go to
them they're not always the most helpful
people they can be and that's like the
number one goal
ross's be the most helpful right we
aren't going to just reject you or say
we can't help you we're actually going
to try to answer whatever the question
is right as long as it's within what we
can do heck so what are those parameters
are they broken into groups or like what
what can we do um is it is it like
broken up into tears or like so uh we we
technically support all of the products
under the Google cloud platform but
sometimes that confuses some of our
customers right um like sometimes we get
questions for like oh we have like oh I
ran out of quota on the Maps API right
Maps API technically isn't under cloud
although it's an API and it used to be
in the developers console right we
sometimes get questions for that but
like if you have a question with
translate API that's under the cloud
umbrella you know the vision API App
Engine those are all the sorts of
products we really help with gotcha cool
so if i have a question say I'm running
on Google cloud platform like where do I
go does it matter like if I'm on a
different maybe different support
package or do I will go to the same
place or what's what avenues are
available to me so um if you're on one
of our higher tiers right so silver gold
or platinum we always recommend that you
come you sign into the Google for work
support center which is how you file
cases with various support teams here at
Google it's where you support cases with
my team if and we always recommend you
come to us first if you're on the bronze
level right um you can post your
questions on the stack overflow or the
google groups public issue trackers and
they're all there and monitored by our
team but it's not where you can get one
to one support right if you want
individual customized responses and
questions the google for support center
is going to be your best place but if if
we see a question and we think it's
going to benefit the commune
we have a whole team of people that sit
and watch all of those mediums and will
answer questions if it's going to
benefit the entire community okay so
going up through the tears we're talking
about bronze / go platinum I believe
everyone is enrolled in blonds
immediately like just because you part
of Google cloud platform is that correct
that is correct excellent okay and
that's what gives you like as soon as
you're there like bronze is really like
that's where you're reaching out to
support through what you're talking
about so there's community mediums those
developer community stack overflow and
those those things are those things are
monitored by the the support engineers
is that correct that is correct yep we
have a whole team that monitors all of
our what we call one too many support
mediums and then you also interact with
other people using google cloud they are
right you know people you know other
customers other users other people with
similar experience in those public
communities yeah some of our bigger
communities such as the it's called GCE
discuss or GC discussion it's a google
group is actually really popular with
members of the community actually
helping each other and support actually
doesn't have to provide a lot of help or
nurturing in those types of situations
and actually community is really active
there you also find a lot of our product
engineers on stackoverflow right they
all follow most of stack overflow or
most teams that have a stack overflow
tag also follow along and provide
answers they're like I know the bigquery
team you will actually get answers from
real bigquery engineers so awesome like
if you have questions there that like I
don't quite understand how this function
works bigquery engineers are there and
they go hey yeah here's this and then
they bring back the information and
actually they improve their
documentation usually it's like Chester
yeah they answer the question excellent
so the Silver Gold and Platinum those do
cost extra money right yes so um I see
they all have sort of different benefits
to those but I think I think I know the
answers question but I'm gonna ask it
anyway woody what do you think is like
the one big reason for people like why
people should pay
for support a google cloud platform so
the the reason why people should pay for
support is the tailored experience in
the google group forums or stack
overflow the answers to the question is
going to be generic and try to help
facilitate a conversation for a wide
variety of audience right people coming
to it later in the paid support you get
tailored one-to-one answers that address
your very specific needs and usually
involve exactly what you're doing cool
and I see also unlike the gold level
it's not just hey I've got a problem but
i believe it's also like i'm trying to
find the best way to do this can you
help me work that out is that that true
uh yeah the that's something we do
actually quite regularly um and i have
some really great stories about things
along those lines oh that's here yeah
let's hear them um yeah so uh one of
them right um we had a customer they're
a really big video game now but before
they got really big right they call us
up and they're like hey we have a
problem and you know we SAT there we
helped them and we actually had two
different support reps sit on the phone
with them for eight hours one day eight
hours the next day and then four hours
the on the third day and we actually
like helped it it was actually quite
interesting to watch to see like the
support wrap and the customer like they
have conversations and they'd be agreed
to be like all right let's go grab a
snack right we'll come back in 15
minutes and we'll continue the
conversation these are kind of the types
of things that we don't mind doing and
it's part of that like additional help
and really they were they were having
some issues around cloud sequel and we
were helping them get past the growing
pains that some customers experience
with cloud sequel brilliant so it sounds
like it's really great not just the hey
I've got a problem but you know I
haven't used this platform before or I
haven't felt this particular thing
before and it allows you to kind of have
that that sanity check or like that
extra pair of eyes to be able to see a
line not doing something completely and
utterly crazy yeah most of the support
reps generally pass a full google
engineering interview and so we all have
experience which distributes
systems and scaling systems and so
actually what we really where you get
like the best benefit from the gold and
platinum support is actually people who
have done these things and so in this
case with this past customer they had a
proof of concept it was running on
Google sequel and then they tried to
throw like joiner time slowed at it and
they're like it kind of fell over and so
like we're helping them facilitate
through those types of things what's the
solution there because I want this to
scale I'm gonna hit I'm gonna get a two
hundred times on my project here with
the answer sure you will um but uh so
actually this was before cloud sequel uh
was our cloud sequel v2 was a big thing
okay and so we actually helped them
install and configure and load test my
sequel running on GCE catch and that
helped him out quite a bit and if
somebody were running to this similar
situation today what would the
recommendation be house sequel v2 okay
cool much faster uh yeah so cloudy cool
v1 has a couple of limitations you know
like the number of connections you could
have or how big it is and the way this
customer was going they needed a lot
more power right and so cloud sequel v2
wasn't quite ready even for beta at the
time and so we really I would recommend
it now like it's no many more
connections much bigger instances it's
pretty amazing awesome so that sounds
like a pretty specific case are there
any common things that people often come
to support for like things you often see
quite regularly yeah um there's a couple
of things uh most of them actually come
from either GCE or cloud sequel there
seems to be a trend here um so
connection limits in class equals
something that happens all the time
something else that happens from cloud
sequel is a sometimes we have to perform
maintenance on your instances and so
sometimes they get rebooted as part of
the maintenance but customers like to
enable the flag called the general log
on their cloud sequel instances and so
even though we rebooted your instance
and it was only down for 15 seconds as
we rebooted it sometimes it can take up
to five hours for your cloud sequel
instance
recover because the is trying to go
through the general log Wow okay wait
how do we how do we avoid this on my
thing that's going to go to 200 x so
cloud sequel v2 allows you to add your
own my sequel facts so just don't add
the enable general log my single file
we're okay okay yeah but that's
something that happens quite often is so
the general logs like really good for
debugging but people forget to disable
it ah when they go like into production
and so then they get bitten by this most
people around 30 minutes right but like
and then customers try to reboot there
because you can do that once it comes
back up you can reboot your cloud sequel
instance and so they only actually
caused themselves more pain when they
click the reboot button I'm so much
longer yeah they'll get 15 minutes in
and be like reboot it's like really just
you got to be patient you got to wait
there's nothing we can do for your
instance you just going to wait so
disable your general logs make sure
those are disabled gotcha whatever the
way yeah rule number one a clot sequel
don't enable the general that's a great
lesson for the day on GCE uh some of the
things that sometimes catch customers is
the lab migrations you know we try to
make them as painless as possible but uh
there are some pieces of software out
there that can't handle you know five
seconds of network like the network not
being available ok so like distributed
clustered systems like Senate like
sub-millisecond or sub-second heartbeats
if you fail like two of them it's like
your nodes dip right and so we've we've
handled that a couple of times and being
like yeah live migrations sometimes can
take one or two seconds in your
software's health beets are a little too
aggressive so if you can you know turn
them down your system won't be you won't
have to do manual recovery of your
initial dish system every time there's a
lot of migration catch am so like those
are kind of a common ones that I well
another common one is actually firewall
rules those trip people of all the time
i was actually handling one today where
some customers really like to like limit
their firewall rules to be like their
offices IP address but very few people
actually have a static IP address oh and
so when there
office like the IP address of their
office changes they're like why can't I
SSH into my instances it's like the IP
address you're trying to login in is
different than your firewall rules allow
so like you have to go to customers
through those sorts of things gotcha so
I'm on you know a cable connection or
something my office and it's on dynamic
dns and one day it just changes yeah you
know sometimes i see customers firewall
rules and it's like Brian's home IP
address oh but they're like I can't
login from home and it's like yep looks
like your IP address changed so can you
just look at these for customers ah look
at what like my firewall rules can you
just look at that yeah um I can wait
really uh with restrictions yeah okay so
how's that work so first off you need to
tell me that there's a problem okay now
as with everything at Google everything
is logged and you need a reason to do
anything right so when you so when you
submit a case I can look at your the
meta information of your project so like
which firewalls you have instances you
have I can't actually log into any of
them but I can see the like name of your
instances so if you're like oh my web
server 01 is acting up I can actually go
and see which instance in your project
is that and then be able to inspect
information about it like how much CPU
is using how much disk in rabbits used
okay so part as part of requesting
support but I'm kind of asking you to be
able to take a look at the metadata
around the project yes okay it'd be
really hard to do our job without being
able to do that or the alternative is um
we play the game of can you run this
g-cloud command and send me the output
right and so that is a possibility but
it's not the most efficient way for us
to help you solve your problem right and
that's when you're already anxious and
you're down in production you'd rather
we just tell you how to solve the
problem then ask you to run 15 commands
for us gotcha that makes a lot of sense
I want to return a little bit to the
different tears inside support so that
people can kind of have a feel for what
tier they might want to use depending on
where they're at with like their Google
cloud platform usage bronze seems very
obvious because well you've already
signed in we talked a little bit about
silver I think to the degree that you're
like okay
you get the personalized experience for
me looking at gold it seems like the big
win there is you get that consultive
ticket so you get that ability to be
able to ask you know give me a guide on
how to build this thing I've never done
it before at what point do you think
people should be moving to from silver
to gold is it just because they have
that sort of need and then also like
what point do you think people should be
moving from gold to platinum so the big
thing I think changing from silver to
gold is when you need that 24 x seven
support that's really the big difference
between civil and gold is there like
when your stuff is down on the weekend
and you need someone to answer your
questions to your business is back up
and running gold is the right one and
specifically that fern support as well
yeah yeah phone support as well and so
even if you look at the target response
times on things so when you're down in
production right I would call that a p1
ticket like priority 1 i'm down I'm
losing money we target to respond within
one hour right when you're on the Silver
level the target to response is for
business hours so if you're down on the
weekend it could be up till one o'clock
Australia time on a Monday when we would
start responding to so if you're on the
specific time it'd be about like nine
o'clock p.m. sunday okay and then from
gold to silver it's only a or from gold
platinum it's only an extension of that
so we target responses in 15 minutes so
if you're a really big customer and you
lose thousands tens of thousands
millions per a minute down Platinum's
the place to be that makes sense it
looks like a the difference there is
this critical impact issues versus high
impact issues what's the difference
there so critical impact is like system
is down in production and not losing
money high impact it's hard to describe
but things just short of that or high
impact it's always hard to just so like
would be classified as priority so P
ones are like systems down and losing
money in production p 2 would be
high-impact it's always hard to describe
what a p2 is so we support you on the
weekends with p2 stuff ok so I noticed
the disc is filling or some
sort of like performance degradation or
you know kind of things are trending
towards bad but they haven't actually
failed yet yeah so like not that it
happens often but let's say for example
you're putting a lot of objects into GCS
and GCS as example Jesus has an error
rate of one percent and you start seeing
GCS go to 2% 3% 45 that would be a time
to file a p2 ticket on platinum well if
you had platinum until it's like hey GCS
error rates are going up I mean our
engineering team should already be aware
of it but like that would be a p2 thing
of like we're kind of going towards the
bad situation can you identify and solve
it before we are actually down in
production ok brilliant ok so it sounded
run out of time just a little bit but
all the support stuff sounds really
great so how do I sign up what's the
best way to get started so uh you can
sign up for silver and gold just by
clicking the buttons on cloud google.com
/ support you'll actually tell you how
to do it for platinum support it
requires a little more work and a little
more effort usually involves a sales
team member to actually start the
process in an offline contract not
necessarily strictly there but that's
generally how the process goes cool but
I can access buttons for that to get in
contact through that same URL i believe
yep wonderful alright and is there
anything else about support that we
haven't covered or you want to say or
plug or anything extra you want to add a
probably the only thing to add is that
or to reiterate is that the people
you're talking on the other ends are
basically Google engineers it's the same
people that comes out of same talent
pool as sui's rsrs here at Google and
they just have some extra skills that we
think make them good to be in this
position that's awesome that is very
very cool all right well Terrence and
Brian thank you so much for joining me
today and joining us here on the Google
cloud platform podcast that was a super
interesting conversation thanks so thank
you so much so Terrence for taking the
time to talk to us today actually not to
us but talk to Brian
mark thank you Brian also for helping us
with his interview absolutely he he
jumped in because i had to reschedule
everything because i managed to hurt
myself with my dog yeah yeah that's a
long story but but fortunately
everything is fine and brian is a he's
actually awesome not only he's helping
us having good Mike's now he's also
helping us interviewing people yep next
step is he will actually just run the
podcast by himself probably yeah yeah
which is slowly fine I got looking
forward to that cool so let's go with a
question of the week absolutely so we
were talking about this a little bit for
it basically it sort of runs along the
lines of say you have your app running
on something like App Engine and you
want to connect to one of the other
Google services that sort of run in the
cloud such as like calendar or possibly
drive I've had this question before as
well I have no idea how to do it but I
do believe you do France desk yeah and I
actually got a this same question but in
a slightly different way I'm gonna share
it because I thought it was really cool
there was these these people that were
doing a little application where you
could take a picture this picture could
be sent to the club vision API they get
the OCR on that so character recognition
on that image and then create a new
document on google docs with the text
recognized from the image which I
thought it was very useful that's cool
so yeah so so the bar is like okay so a
google cloud vision API obviously use
the API how do you do like the docs part
of it and there's actually a couple of
ways of doing it but the easiest one is
using the seem to simply the rest api
google mosque google services they
provide an api and it's mostly raised
ApS is also sometimes a grp capi but
you're going to see rest api s which
means that you can use them from
anywhere and you can use them very
easily from your own machine if you want
to try them out there's also something
that i think that people should know
about if you have never tried it it's a
google api is explorer which is actually
basically a playground where you can see
all the api's we are
we offer and then you can directly from
there just fill the gaps like feel the
fields that you want to try they just
run it and it manages all the all the
authentication a part of it so it's very
nice but obviously you can also you do
that from any primary language running
anywhere so you can do it directly from
compute engine from container engine and
if you're doing it from App Engine
you're going to need to use things like
URL fetch which allows you to do HTTP
request from an app engine instance to
the outside world cool now do I need to
build those rest request myself are
there any like SDKs or client tools that
I could use to make my life a little bit
easier yeah that is a very good question
so if you are the kind of person that
wants to create everything by himself by
themselves totally fine you can't I do
that but we also offer a bunch of
libraries that are gentler basically
offered the same functionality but in an
idiomatic way so for instance for Google
Docs you can see that there's like Java
JavaScript net objective-c PHP Python
and then also dart and go obviously and
not judge as Ruby and I'm pretty sure
this is been more than that but
basically all of those libraries are
developed sometimes by our engineers so
basically they're going to be very very
idiomatic and they're going to feel like
normal libraries sometimes for other
services you will see that they're
actually auto-generated so it will not
be as idiomatic but still is easier than
running the the whole request yourself
that makes a lot of sense so yep so you
can check it out we'll have the links on
the show notes and that way you can
easily integrate google cloud
applications with google services sweet
that sounds really great excellent well
we both seem to be a little bit out and
about but any particular events you're
going to be at in the next few weeks
France ask so I've heard about this
conference on sounds that sounds very
interesting i think it's called google
i/o I've heard about this what is that
yeah I know it's going to be happening
in montview so yeah I'll be there
we'll be there will be never be speaking
yeah I'm going to be speaking about
Google clots been excellent I will be
there also talking about multiplayer
games with firebase cool and after that
i will go to chicago for my first time
ever for go to very nice i'll also be
standing around at some of the the areas
will have at google i/o so you can come
and talk to Googlers and to the chat to
us about the problems or things you want
to solve as well so definitely swing by
i'll be there as well as many of my
peers cool yeah i'll be also they're
wearing a google cloud platform podcast
t-shirt I would never take that t shirt
off I am constantly a t-shirt yeah
you're actually wearing it right now I
am wearing it right now absolutely
that's amazing uh but just for people to
know we have more than one so we
actually watch them there's one more
than one go klappa from t-shirt go to
apply from podcast assured there ya go
great so before we say goodbye why don't
we remind people how to contact us
because I think there's something new
today there is something new today
there's a new URL that you can reach our
website I know it doesn't seem like a
big thing you can get to us at JCP
podcast com it is a huge thing that's
pretty cool now you can get to us at
cloud google com / podcast makes us feel
very very official or even XR official
yeah but yeah cloud or google com /
podcast will take you to gcb podcast
come and the two of us yeah very cool
also if you want to send us an email you
can send it to hello ji soo podcaster
come we're also on Twitter at at gcp
podcast we are also in google plus as
plus gcp podcast we have a subreddit at
/ r / gcp podcast and a slack community
not slack channel select community yeah
well inside the slack community we have
a channel hash podcast that you can
reach us at as well and i'm almost sure
i'm forgetting something as usual but no
i think that's it I think we're good Wow
amazing yeah I remember all of them cool
so think of a much mark to take time off
your trip to Kentucky to record this
episode absolutely wouldn't miss it for
the world and looking forward to talking
to you next week face to face this next
time yeah see you back in San Francisco
next week
they're right
you